previously on blackout Club Satan what
just happens what's going on beyond the
door we it knows the little is this like
a situation where the developers are
talking to us you know what I mean
join us below little skirm okay it's the
developers all right we can't possibly
screw up a third time somebody but I
might have made some noise your
grappling hook was useful though a foot
I am gonna get the grappling hook
because in that last area if I had it I
was like oh yeah I'd be able to climb up
this all over the place that it's true
apparently someone in my chat saying it
is just the devs [ __ ] with us
well yeah that little skirm Conda gave
it away why didn't they talk about
little bum bum yeah they don't want to
give you any more attention steel pick
up signal relays all right so is it
possible to do this yes have you
actually completed a mission here before
yeah we've beat like four or five of
them they're honestly not usually this
hard like it used to be like one
objective it was like grab three things
and get out like this this multi-step
thing I don't think we dealt with that
is it the developers it could be I mean
I have a feeling with minion and scre me
where me and everything else maybe
they're influencing it a bit know
there's a camera drone over here what
the hell is this just be able to disable
the cameras and I still have yet to be
able to disable a single one I'm
disabling the speed traps and I have to
be up next to him we could check these
houses for the bonus evidence now I
don't know that you guys care that much
about it but it's like I just want to
beat a level why am i already hearing
spoop noises get out of here with that
here spooky noises what are you hearing
and when I walked past that light it was
all spooky doesn't seem right against my
better judgment which is what I always
do I'm gonna go into this house here
okay I'm gonna keep following mark very
closely and you know is periodically to
see what have we got a dude here whoa
this backyard is guarded holy [ __ ] is
some serious lockdown okay it's below is
that trap door that we could go in no
other cameras coming back though the
camera where the light is shining right
is out here because that's something we
can go in it looks like maybe yeah maybe
yeah like a bunker door yeah I'm gonna
try it oh god oh god please
we're fine together okay yeah this is
definitely something we can go in I'm
gonna do this speed trap in case we need
to come back out in some sort of hurry
okay
all right I'm down here hey there's
there's six things down here so they're
all down here along with some bonus
objective I think oh yeah that's bonus
objective are you doing fine the bonus
objectives all right you take three I
take three oh no what was that I shot my
tranq dart accidentally whoo your tranq
load already
the holes that noise we completed them
objective I know you've never heard it
before Wade but we did it oh lady came
in in the lock doors
it's a weird song I don't like your song
get a better song dude Bob said he
doesn't like your song get a better song
right now Bob that's for rap I got no
pants but I'm not wearing that
cuz [ __ ] [ __ ] crap crap dude family
friendly what the hell were demonetized
now a poopy do pee soupy whoop whoop
whoop I'm good at handkerchief on mop
you ride with poop already there's like
cameras and wait a minute yeah wait a
minute I'm gonna let it go and then I'm
gonna go okay I'm going oh you're good
I'm going I'm gonna drop the last bit
here watch that speed trap oh man sucks
to be away from the team donut
oh it sure do I'm coming what's the fall
damage like in this game don't know
great question
alright thanks okay yeah what how am I
in the camera what you're good you're
good the boxes I know that it was all
wound up all right I think we got a
clear shot to wherever the hell this
thing is
what the hell no what does that sound
what did you do and do nothing
got one dude down here this is a hundred
and ten meters away where this is a very
large complex what are they making here
it's like some kind of factory there's a
projection of P boo yoga I just want you
guys to know I found no evidence great
good work dude really putting your time
to good use
thank you hey let me know if you see a
frog that turns into a snake that'd be
really cool oh I took a wrong turn at
the Frog wait have you brought even a
single thing back to the camp hang on I
swear the frog was real
the Frog Tiger
Queen I'm actually worried you're ador
there yeah I gotta believe the Frog
turned into a tiger yeah okay I do okay
well I was like a month ago hey I see
you guys you're far from me yeah sure
are yeah Wow mark there's a box over
here you want the stuff that's in this
box
tell me what's in it there's a flashbang
and an energy bar going for it I can't
take either of them apparently why not
you guys get messages again nope okay to
answer your question I'm not you can
have them all yours uh-huh okay that
door right in front of us mark that I
feel like something bad is about to come
out of let's just not go there I'll do
this for myself not for them you can
have them all yours are you trying to
sell us out
no I'm what would I be selling you out -
there's been no messages Debs if you're
listening I was fighting to know that
Wade abandoned his friends he lives in
Ohio while the rest of us living no
Horgan excuse me he abandoned us and
that's all you need to know about him
and his character tonight god I got a
lock visit mark Oh God I'm stuck I need
to lockpick it done oh there's a guy
right by me mark
what is okay very bright in this room
very guys I found the way you went down
Oh which one is the worst of them who's
the worst mark Bob you were Bob what I
feel like it's definitely you yeah it's
clearly you Bob it is you answered my
question by pointing the finger at me
all right um I'm making a real a quick
stir turn on your friend that's my
entire thing listen if you guys have
never watched this play games together
before my whole shtick is that I like to
turn on my friends so I'm doing that's
that's not a negative statement about my
character in any way just Who I am you
know just being myself oh oh we need to
build the path with these relays you
just see each other Oh
there are two more let's do this without
you guys no it's fine you okay sure sure
no no no that's not what I wanted
that was a flashbang what the hell it
makes truths telling a lie
I that's that's actually pretty pretty
accurate to my character as well I'm the
nice one yeah you're the nice one
it's guaranteed absolutely okay so we
just need to build this relay back to
the other area up here how do I do that
you open the item that it's in your slot
oh I see okay yeah yeah I guess we
should have been building them the other
way yeah we could have done like ninety
percent of this we would have been done
already if only we knew how this game
worked this was not a mission I ever had
before I mean feel free to place him but
no I don't want to like double play so
I'm gonna let you I'll let you do it and
until you want me to do it and then I'll
start plopping them down uh you guys
would never betray me right is I just I
just had this thought betrayed you must
have this yet today fine all right cool
good good I just wanted to double-check
I'm the nice one
I would never liked it we've got your
back I know I know you do I know like a
name the last time we betrayed you today
dude I can't even think of one yeah
exactly
all right uh Bob I've got three lower
you up all right
I'm gonna just please I got 15 left so
if that wasn't in the right spot there
we go where's my camera
no there it is okay see all right my
last ones coming up in three two one
okay I'm out so it'll do growl in your
hand if it ruptures
yeah I can disable the camera here
because if the guy on your left
yeah we see him
what is that noise he's planned to music
ma'am
okay is bonging let me know what you
want camera off now would be great it
only stays off for 15 seconds so there
you go okay I should be enough for me I
don't know if it's enough for Wade I'm
wait guys you wouldn't happen to
yourself when you talk do you have
deceit in your voice deceit no
definitely not
no I literally just saved you guys from
the horrible camera monster well I would
have a bobby kotick ladder oh oh it's
locked onto me oh no you got something
coming behind you you got one bike [ __ ]
alright yeah now what a little more
warning that that would have been
helpful a flashbang him please sir I
think I flash bring him okay do you have
a relay and line-of-sight there on that
wall there maybe I said the shape was
coming yeah that's okay we should go we
should go shape is coming up the ladder
shape is coming up the ladder I hope you
guys are building your stuff oh we're so
close Bob we're so close Jesus he's
coming for me it's not a problem
oh [ __ ] okay so close wait Bob I can't
place one I can't place well now I'm
dead what oh no not here do you do you
have any jet radio no no I dunno I'm
gonna come back for it
[ __ ] also trust
Oh I place two of them but in the Curan
correct spots she's right
you're friendly now right you know I'm
gonna risk it where's my Oh where's my
flashbang oh I traded it that's right I
forgot
whoopsie doodles
alright oh god damn it
oh wow that hurt my rope goes there's
another one there's another one marked
careful all right I'm just trying to
climb off my rope
I'm climbed my rope marker you just hide
- give me your rope yep well I think
you're the only don't let go the
betrayer is ours better now all [ __ ] off
my are safe on this letter I'm gonna go
with no Bob how's the relays going it's
done it's done oh hey oh I don't think
I'm safe on the ladder um why would you
rescue a trainer because I wanted to
build the relays form yet if you like
doing manual labor
how you doing guards or fine we're
absolutely fine sometimes you just need
labor to be done for you oh wait the
relays don't connect Oh shouldn't I just
stupid dumb self I can fix this I can
fix this okay could totally fix this
guys no problemo wait there was there
was a relay on the ground that you could
use to keep building are you where are
you oh are you down mark are you good no
I'm up I'm good from it I'm I knee can
you hack the camera for me maybe hello
the ships coming for me but good luck
finding me it's fine it's fine
such arrogance dude I will find a way to
break your game developpers trust you me
that's my specialty
there are so many [ __ ] patrolling
this stupid room where is the bag I
can't see the objective anymore
it's down here I don't think I can get
to I mean my God in heaven I'm so extra
boned right I did I named you as one I
named you again we speak
is one we do we're all we're all one
here
listen shape Lord I love your shape it
appeals to me in a deep way please don't
name it or don't name it shape Lord oh
Jesus Christ
edge of bush eyes it what sin did you
get me no okay welcome I'm being dragged
that coming to you I think I'm down
where we were before mark yeah I'm
coming to Gamma Rho and thanks for the
disabled coming for Bob but he's down oh
no the shape is upon me I get it
oh damn it oh damn it not enough time
not enough time god damn it damn it damn
it damn oh god no boy I'm wounded oh boy
I'm sprinting so far away from you mark
speed trap I'm hurting wait you could
come to the next area and yeah I'm
working on it
you're gonna wanna something yeah
they're coming I'm on some weight push
them the flashing I don't have enough
health to push anymore
Oh speed trap wait speed trap oh my god
Marcus being drags ro but do you see you
could have okay I'm being dragged
towards the objectives
oh sure wall park weights dragging them
towards you [ __ ] is just like ah take
this guy get off of here I don't think
my god what's the objective I don't even
get to see that anymore marks on my team
now let's just get away you spew oh okay
that's the bag so we just gotta get it
out right well we gotta get to Bob what
does the [ __ ] is Bob yeah I think he's a
commie the hell up top I'm walking
around in a backyard there's a bandage
in here do you have a bandage can you
get a bandage out of the thing I need
one so bad you guys are not super far
from me but I'm in I'm in a backyard
okay is the objective up or down up it's
gotta be right yeah it looks like it's
up I think we got to go out of the hole
that we came in and then go alright I
don't know how we're alive I [ __ ] that
so many ways from Sunday
okay try joining the beggar I am I'm
kind of doing those things I'm stalking
them train of sacrifice I locked mark in
a room with monsters I feel like if
anyone's made sacrifices to date me you
Mia you have sacrifice yes you're right
all right I'm back the shape still has
me okay we see you on the map wait if we
go right is that gonna like take us to
the elevator because that seems to be
where Bob is I'm opening doors I'm
navigating here I'm going places yeah
towards you guys I'm outside on the
street right now yeah we're coming gonna
come up the elevator pretty close to
where you are we think yeah I think if I
remember where that it alright I'm safe
I just like bumped into us leaving birth
three times he named us hey have you
been saying names Bob no no no I think
Bob's been saying the name now we will
take him for you for us okay listen guys
all cards are the table I think it's
coming for me now Wow listen I've made
sacrifices okay Bob we're almost to you
yeah yeah I see you guys I in the house
that you might be able to come up it I
just walked in this house I'm gonna try
sneak up on you I think that might be
the best way to go hello chat for sure
the devs have control of sleeping me all
right you guys are in the next house I'm
going towards you though let's go
they're like delivering me to you I'm
okay I don't know if that's good or bad
for you but back up with I hear
footsteps oh no we're good we're good
we're good we're good we're good
all right now I'm wandering around in a
side yard okay I'm coming out a window
oh [ __ ] oh I'm navigating away from I
think they might be what what the hell
they think they are safe what what I
can't I'm in the trees all right go for
it I guess
don't worry Bob I'm coming for you I'm
stuck
are you like bugs stuck I don't know I
think I can get out no oh yeah I just
gotta go back mark there's a lot of
chunky monkey no he says near you yeah
there's a lot of shapes there's like
there's like four shapes they think they
are safe there's like 20 shapes wait no
there's 300 shapes all right our
objective is this way wait must exit
together we could just let him get mark
and then get out of here hey wait Mark's
kind of right next to where we need to
go yeah just come back this way there's
like 23,000 shapes
oh the shapes on me run friends I'll
sacrifice myself again little skirt
betrays what Bob would you do this time
I don't know what I did I think the
criteria for betrayal the developers are
just kind of look I don't want to say it
but I think they're just [ __ ] I
think they're just I think we just haul
ass to the exit I'm not sure if these
are these real shapes okay I'm coming I
think I don't think these shapes are
real I think they're all fake Bob where
are you talking will definitely help us
here oh I see it I literally see a shape
mark we got to go okay I just [ __ ] it
full speed
kick that door in I got the hell out of
there man one bonus evidence we got to
do better I did that hey we got candy oh
I said let's just let market take it and
leave so apparently betraying each other
is the trigger oh well that's gonna be
really hard for me not to do I gotta be
hey we did one guy's good you were
dreaming do you wish to remember sure
you know son you wearing deodorant today
I know
it's ninja oh is it
he's making fun of our week mindset oh
you're right God it's cuz I didn't get
angry when I lost
[Music]